[Music]
a time-traveling robot cat a Monster
hunting afterlife and a city engulfed in
bubbles Netflix has some serious anime
gems you don't want to miss
in a post-apocalyptic future the
remnants of humanity live inside a
labyrinth and technological city-state
and are hunted by spider-like robots
known as the Safeguard the 2017 anime
action film blame offers Humanity's
salvation in the form of Kylie a black
clad Warrior from below who rescues a
young girl named zuru from the Safeguard
in search of a human being who possesses
the net terminal Gene that can control
the robots Keeley teams up with zuru and
sibo a cyborg who predates the
techno-apocalypse to save zuru's Village
conceptually dense and packed with skull
crushing action blame earns the
exclamation point in its title Attack on
Titan director tetsuro araki envisions a
transformed Tokyo in this
post-apocalyptic remix of The Little
Mermaid five years before the events of
the film mysterious bubbles began
falling from the sky triggering strange
gravitational abnormalities now with the
entire city of Tokyo encased in an
enormous bubble teams of surviving
teenagers battle for supplies via
dangerous parkour games when one game
knocks a young blue blazes team member
named hibiki to the Sea a strange girl
called utta manifests out of bubbles to
rescue him who is utta where did she
come from and what forgotten secret
binds her and hibiki together bubble
explores these questions with skillful
writing and eye-popping animation
beautiful
athletic sixth grader Khanna has lost
her passion for running after the
traumatic death of her mother but on the
day of the school Marathon Kana wears
her mother's bracelet and discovers its
mystical ability to slow time to a crawl
as it turns out khana's running ability
is part of a magical Birthright
accompanied by a talking rabbit and a
fleet-footed demon boy she must hurry
across Japan and gather offerings for a
special Feast for deities Before Time
Runs Out populated by likable characters
and Visually appealing Gods child of
kamiari month is a clever and absorbing
fantasy travelogue man's relationship to
the environment has been a powerful
theme in anime for a long time and
Children of the sea a young girl named
Ruka discovers her profound connection
to the ocean when she meets Umi and Sora
brothers raised underwater with
Supernatural aquatic abilities as Ruka
tries to understand this connection she
is submerged into a mystery about
disappearing sea life children of the
sea engulfs its audience with
psychedelic visuals and profound
questions about man's place in the
natural world
sixth graders kosuke and natsume were
drifting apart but now they are drifting
home
ever do it unless we cooperate you
little idiot quit acting like my sister
because you're not my sister
when the old abandoned apartment
building they grew up in faces
demolition the former best friends
reconnect on top of the roof this all
ages adventure takes on a survivalist
spin when a flash flood suddenly sends
the apartment building adrift in a
mysterious seemingly Endless Sea
separating kosuke natsume and their
friends from the rest of the world the
children will have to rely on their wits
if they're going to make it home luckily
they have help in the form of nopo the
ghost haunting the apartment building
drifting home is a smart satisfying and
occasionally surreal coming-of-age story
Neon Genesis Evangelion is a genre
smashing classic and one of the defining
shows of the 1990s not just for Mecca
anime but for the medium itself the
story follows a 14 year old boy who
reluctantly Pilots the giant robot
Evangelion unit 0-1 against invading
interdimensional beings called Angels
Evangelion was revolutionary in its
combination of thrilling action striking
visuals in and a story that turned its
young hero psyches into battlefields The
End of Evangelion is as the title
promises the conclusion to the original
Evangelion TV series The Last Angel has
been destroyed leaving the Ava Pilots
despondent Shinji hot-headed Oscar and
enigmatic Ray to face one final enemy
Humanity visceral shocking and Brilliant
the end of the End of Evangelion is
still discussed today cementing its
place as a modern anime classic
I'm sure I'll just realize the obvious
over
fireworks puts an imaginative spin on a
story about a young boy's first love nor
amichi secretly loves his classmate
nazuna a beautiful but troubled girl
planning to run away from home on the
day of their Town's fireworks festival
nor amichi is helpless to stop mizuna's
mother from forcibly taking her back
home upset and heartbroken noramichi
throws a glass marble belonging to
nazuna and wishes that he could turn
back time to his surprise the marble
creates an alternate timeline where
nazuna and noramichi run away together
but how many wishes and Alternate worlds
will it take for the Star-Crossed couple
to finally Escape their pursuers tender
and thoughtful fireworks is highly
invested in the dreams and fears of its
young protagonists leading to an
emotionally explosive finale high school
student matsuru Kato is on his way home
for his little brother's birthday when a
random attacker stabs him in the subway
Kato should be dead but instead of the
afterlife he wakes up in an austere
White Room containing several strangers
and a mysterious black sphere called
Gans after outfitting Kato with a
special suit and futuristic weapons
Gantz orders this team to hunt down
monsters invading the city if they win
they can regain their freedom but if
they fail the entire team will die
bursting with unconventional Heroes and
hideous monsters gants O is a
relentlessly paced action thriller that
gives viewers a taste of the ultraviolet
Gams franchise
[Music]
in the near future giant monsters
overrun the Earth and Humanity's only
chance for survival is to flee the
planet with help from alien technology
Twenty Thousand Years Later humans
returned to find the Earth's environment
transformed into a world that now
belongs to Godzilla Kaiju fans who can't
get enough of the king of the monsters
should seek out Godzilla planet of the
monsters the first computer animated
film in the franchise's history the
far-flung future setting puts a unique
spin on a classic formula and without
the confines of live-action filmmaking
Godzilla is a more terrifying force of
nature than ever before a young boy
takes a Fantastical climb up his family
tree in Mirai a sweet and profound film
by acclaimed Bell director mamaru hasida
four-year-old Kuhn is upset by the
sudden presence of his new baby sister
Mirai and throws tantrums around his
parents a teenage girl then appears
telling [ __ ] she's Mirai from the future
[ __ ] goes on a magical journey through
his family's past gaining a better
understanding of his parents sister and
himself in 2000 19 Mirai was nominated
for best animated feature at the Academy
Awards becoming the first non-studio
Ghibli anime film to earn the
distinction
anime fans can explore the legendary
giant robot franchise from the very
beginning with Mobile Suit Gundam 1. the
first of three compilation films retell
the events of the original 1979 anime
television series Mobile Suit Gundam
introduces amuro Ray a young burgeoning
psychic also known as a new type and
pilot for the experimental Mobile Suit
weapon known as the Gundam engaged in an
Intergalactic war amuro fights to defend
his friends and allies and forms a
lifelong rivalry with the enigmatic Mast
pilot Char aznabel Mobile Suit Gundam 1
and its two companion films are
essential viewing for any Mecca anime
fan to see them is to understand why the
Gundam franchise has captivated
audiences for over 40 years
energetic young ninja Naruto Uzumaki
trains so that he can one day become
leader of his village but his trust in
his teacher is tested in Naruto
Shippuden the movie the will of fire a
celebratory film for the Naruto series
10th anniversary the will of fire
follows Naruto's pursuit of their
teacher Kakashi after he deserts their
Village in actuality an evil ninja has
cursed Kakashi so that he may absorb his
power and Naruto is determined to save
his mentor before he can sacrifice
himself Naruto Shippuden the movie the
will of fire combines the fluid
fast-paced action the series is known
for with an encouraging story about
overcoming seemingly impossible odds we
have to protect the leaf Village I love
that's the only future that matters
that's the future that children need
recently orphaned in a car accident
young OKO moves into the Inn operated by
her grandmother and prepares to become
its new caretaker the Inn rejects no one
according to her grandmother which is
lucky for OKO because she can see and
communicate with the ghosts haunting it
okozen is a cheeky collection of
Spirited vignettes it touches on death
openly and gently with the spirits
helping OKO come to terms with her grief
as they all prepare to move on to the
next stage of their existence
one piece is an international pop
culture phenomenon the original manga
series has over 490 million copies in
print shattering world records and the
official anime adaptation has aired over
1 000 episodes since 1999. the sheer
immensity of One Piece may seem
intimidating for viewers eager to dive
into the adventures of Monkey D Luffy a
boy pirate whose body gains the
elasticity of rubber after eating a
devil fruit one place to start one-piece
Strong World a feature-length film with
an original story developed by one piece
Creator Ichiro Oda in Strong World Luffy
and the straw hat Pirates are scattered
after the evil Shiki who also has a
devil fruit power abducts their
Navigator Nami showcasing oda's
eye-catching character designs and spry
storytelling one piece strong world is a
buoyant and exciting Adventure the
ultimate magical girl the Sailor suited
hero who fights for love and Justice
Shines on the screen in pretty Guardian
Sailor Moon eternal the movie split into
two films on Netflix this faithful
adaptation
beloved manga series Chronicles sailor
Moon's battles against the dead Moon
circus released during a solar eclipse
these colorful minions of the wicked
Queen nehelania threaten everything
Sailor Moon and the Sailor Guardians
hold dear but a mysterious Pegasus named
Helios who appears in Sailor Chibi
Moon's dreams may hold the key to their
salvation pretty Guardian Sailor Moon
eternal the movie has it all friendship
Adventure talking cats evil queens
circus girls from space flying dream
horses and yes love and Justice what
would you do if you could go back in
time to meet your
great-great-grandparents would you tell
them about the future ask them about
their past or give them a robotic cat
from the 22nd century to help them
straighten out their disastrous lives
the touching and imaginative family film
Stand By Me Doraemon chooses the third
option fifth grader Nobi is bullied at
school and in danger of failing his
classes when he's visited by his future
descendant and gifted with a talking
robot cat named Doraemon with the help
of Doraemon and his endless array of
gadgets nobody has the power to give
himself a better future but if he
succeeds will his new best friend leave
him forever what is the strangest thing
you've ever done for love whatever your
answer middle schooler Mio Sasaki has it
beat Mio's outgoing personality hides a
broken heart her father has recently
remarried and her crush hinode is
totally unresponsive to her feelings
thanks to a mysterious mask seller Mio
acquires a mask that turns her into a
cat whenever she wears it posing as a
stray cat named Taro Mio can forget her
troubles and even win hanode's
affections however every gift has a
price and Mio risks being trapped in her
cat form forever
I'm in trouble under its magical
trappings a whisker away is a sweet and
genuine love story that takes the
complex emotions of its young heroine
seriously even when she's an adorable
white kitten words bubble up like soda
pop is a movie as bubbly and
effervescent as its title Cherry is an
introverted teenager who works with
senior citizens and prefers to express
himself via handwritten haikus smile is
a popular streamer and online influencer
who self-consciously hides her braces
behind a face mask after a mix-up at a
local mall their Fates are intertwined
for a glorious shining summer every
frame of Kiowa ishiguru's sweet rom-com
pops with vibrancy and color resulting
in a viewing experience so joyful the
screen practically glows
no no no no no no no no no no